you mentioned danielle add in spotify um
what do you think about that as an
artist what's spotify is that empowering
i get to me spotify server as a consumer
is super exciting it makes it easy for
me to access music from all kinds of
artists
get to explore all kinds of music make
it
super easy to sort of curate my own
playlist and have fun with all that it
was so liberating to let go you know i
used to collect you know albums and cds
and so on like
like like horde albums yeah like they
matter but the reality you could you
know that was really liberating that can
let go of that and
letting go of the albums you're kind of
collecting allows you to find new music
exploring new artists and all that kind
of stuff but i know from a perspective
of an artist that could be like you
mentioned competition could be a kind of
constraint
because there's more and more and more
artists
on the platform i think it's better that
there's more artists i mean again this
might be propaganda because this is all
for a conversation with daniel x so this
could easily be propaganda dude like
we're all a victim of somebody's
propaganda so let's just accept this
but daniel eck was telling me that uh
you know at the because i you know when
when i met him i like i was i came in
all furious about spotify and like i
grilled him super hard so i've got his
his um answers here
but um
uh he was saying like at the sort of
peak of the cd industry there was like
20 000 artists making millions and
millions of dollar dollars like there
was just like a very tiny kind of one
percent
um and spotify has kind of democratized
uh the industry um because now i think
he said there's about a million artists
making a good living from spotify and
when i heard that i was like honestly
i would rather make less money and have
just like a decent living
um
then and have more artists be able to
have that
even though i like i wish it could
include everyone but yeah that's really
hard to argue with youtube is the same
is
youtube's mission they want to
basically
have as many creators as possible make a
living some kind of living yeah and that
that's so hard to argue with
but i think there's better ways to do it
my manager i actually wish he was here i
like i would have brought him up my
manager is um building an app that um
can manage
you
so it'll like help you organize your
percentages and um get your publishing
and da da da so you can take out all the
middlemen so you can have a much bit
bigger it'll just like automate it um so
you can get it to automate the manager
automate automate managing management
publishing um
like and and and and legal it can read
the app he's building can read your
contract and like tell you about it
because one of the issues with music
right now
it's not that we're not getting paid
enough but it's it's that
the art art industry is filled with
middlemen because
artists are not good at business and
you know from the beginning like frank
sinatra it's all mob stuff like it's the
music industry um you know is run by
business people not the artists and the
artists really get very small cuts of
like what they make and so
um i think
part of the reason i'm a technocrat
which i mean your fans are gonna be
technocrats so no one's
they're not going to be mad at me about
this but like my fans hate it when i say
this kind of thing or the general public
they don't like congrats they don't like
technocrats like when i mean when i
watched um battle angel elita and they
were like the martian technocracy and i
was like yeah martian technocracy and
then they were like and they're evil and
i was like oh okay yeah i was like does
martian technocracy sound sick to me
yeah so your intuition
as technocrats would create a some kind
of beautiful world for example what my
manager's working on if you can create
an app that um
removes the need for a lawyer and then
you could you could have a smart
contract on the blockchain um removes
the need uh
for like management and organizing all
the stuff like can um read your stuff
and explain it to you can collect your
royalties
you know like then
the small amounts the amount of money
that you're getting from spotify
actually means a lot more
um and goes a lot farther they can
remove some of the bureaucracy some of
the inefficiencies that
uh make life not as great as it could be
yeah i think the issue isn't that
there's not enough
like the issue is that there's
inefficiency and i'm really into this um
positive sum
mindset um you know the win-win mindset
of like
instead of you know fighting over the
scraps how do we make the
or worrying about scarcity like instead
of a scarcity mindset why don't we just
increase the efficiency
um and you know in that way
you